قله النوم تؤثر على الاقتصاد بحسب دراسه
اجرتها مؤسسه الابحاث الامريكيه
وخلصت الى ان الدول تفقد ما يصل الى 3% من
المحلي الاجمالي بسبب قله النوم ذلك نظرا
لان النوم السيء يتسبب في ارتفاع مخاطر
الوفيات فضلا عن خسائر الانتاجيه في العمل
ما دعى الى نمو ويسمى باقتصاد النوم الناس
بداوا في ادراك نقصهم للنوم خاصه بعد
الوباء وحقيقه ان الناس يعرفون انهم بحاجه
الى الحصول على مزيد من النوم المتواصل
يعطي فرصه لشركات بيع المراتب وحلول النوم
الاخرى وتنقسم منتجات وخدمات النوم الى
ثلاث فئات الاول تحسين الاجواء ويشمل
اثاثوره في النوم والتحكم في الصوت ودرجه
الحراره والثاني التعديل الروتيني ويشمل
استشارات النوم واجهزه مراقبه النوم
والمنبهات الذكيه اما العلاج الثالث فيجمل
وسائل المساعده على النوم كالوصفات الطبيه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]